رقصة من الروبوتات
مصممة بشكل مثالي لتلبية احتياجات
تجارة العصر الرقمي ،
هذا هو التايلاندية الآن الذراع اللوجستية
لعملاق التكنولوجيا الصينية علي بابا
في مستودعاتهم خارج شنغهاي ، حيث
يتم فرز عدد لا يحصى من السلع
وتخزينها وتجهيزها
للتوزيع في
جميع أنحاء العالم في الصين العام الماضي.
بعد تحليلنا ، قمنا بإنتاج أكثر من 60
مليار طرد سنويًا
وهو ما يمثل 60 في المائة من إجمالي
الطرد الذي تم إنشاؤه في العالم بأسره ،
وهو ما يزيد عن ضعف ما تم
إنشاؤه
فينا الآن ، حيث أمضى لين وون تسع سنوات
في أمازون في سياتل قبل أخذ
علامة الخوذة  الآن
تم إطلاق شركة الخدمات اللوجستية في عام
2013 وتهدف إلى توصيل طرد إلى أي
جزء من الصين في
غضون 24 ساعة و 72 ساعة على
مستوى العالم ، فإن اقتصاديات الحجم في علي بابا على مستوى العالم
تتجاوز إدراك ما
قد يفكر فيه معظم الناس عندما يفكرون في
شركة للتجارة الإلكترونية  يحتوي على نظام دفع
يعمل بكامل طاقته
ويحتوي على وسائل ترفيه ،
لذا حاول أن تتخيل facebook
أو google ، ثم أضف
إلى ذلك  eir نظامهم الأساسي
netflix واه أنت تعرف منصات دفع مختلفة
أم وما إلى ذلك ، ويمكنك أن ترى كيف يعمل
النظام البيئي أو المجتمع على بابا
على نطاق واسع للغاية على
النطاق الذي
يقول لين على بابا أنه يتطلب خفة الحركة في كل
جانب من جوانب العملية اللوجستية
حيث تأتي الرقمنة في
أهم شيء بالنسبة للخدمات اللوجستية
في الصين هو
كيفية رقمنة جميع العناصر
الأساسية للوجستيات ، وكيف نقوم برقمنة كل طرد
كيف نرقم كل شخص رقميًا حتى
نمنحهم
جهازًا يدويًا حتى يمكن
تعيين المهام
ديناميكيًا  قمنا برقمنة كل
مستودع وأهم شيء وراء ذلك
هو
أننا نريد بناء نظام رشيق
في العام الماضي ، زرت مستودع الشركة
في الفترة التي تسبق يوم العزاب
أو ضاعف 11 فرصة تسوق عبر الإنترنت
وأكبر
بقرة نقدية لهذا العام على بابا  في عام
2020 ، جمعت الشركة ما يقرب من 75 مليار
دولار على مدى أربعة أيام
في الأيام التي سبقت مضاعفة أحد
عشر وفي د  ays التي
تتبعها كلها عملية على سطح السفينة هنا لديك
تقريبًا كل محطة فرز مفردة
حيث يعمل الأشخاص هنا للحصول على
العملاء حزمهم في أسرع وقت
ممكن ونحن نتحدث عن
الملايين من الطرود حيث تنتهي الروبوتات
من  فرزها
هنا ، والأمر متروك
للعاملين في البشر للبدء في صندوق التعبئة
تلو الآخر
عندما تفكر في ملايين
الحزم التي تخرج بشكل طبيعي وأنت
تفكر في البيئة جيدًا ، أحد الأشياء
التي يفعلها الكمبيوتر هنا
هو أنه يحسب  الحجم الدقيق لكل
شحنة ، قم بصندوق العناصر التي تدخل
فيه بحيث تترك مساحة صغيرة قدر
الإمكان لأي نفايات ، لذا فهذه هي
الخطوة الأخيرة في
عملية الحزم التي تمر عبر هذا
الماسح الضوئي الحزام الناقل
لتنبيه العملاء بأن
طرودهم قيد التشغيل  الطريقة التي سيذهبون بها بعد ذلك
إلى هذه الشاحنات
اعتمادًا على الحي الذي يتجهون إليه
على نطاق واسع أمر لا يصدق ، لذا بالنسبة لكم
يا رفاق في النهاية اللوجستية للأشياء ،
يبدأ الأمر  في الصدارة ،
حتى المبيعات عبر الإنترنت وتجار التجزئة
يركزون ويستمر الأمر جيدًا بعد
ذلك لأنك تستمر في تحقيق
ذلك ، نعم ، علينا الاعتماد على جميع
شركائنا معًا
للتعامل مع مثل هذا الارتفاع المفاجئ ، ولا توجد
منصة واحدة أو واحدة  يمكن للشركة التعامل
مع هذا النوع من المقياس ،
لذلك نعمل مع لدينا الآلاف من
أكبر الشركاء حول العالم ،
نبدأ في إعداد الأشياء من يوليو من
كل عام ،
ونمنح كل الحجم المتوقع حسب
المسار من
خلال محطة تلو الأخرى مركز المصدر حتى
يمكن أن تبدأ جميع براءات الاختراع لدينا  يتم تشغيل الإعداد
وتشغيله ويكون جاهزًا تمامًا
قبل نهاية wwe
tsai الآن مما يعني أن الصاعد في اللغة الصينية
يمثل طموحات
علي بابا لتحويل الطريقة التي نتداول بها من
خلال الاعتماد على إمكانات
أتمتة الروبوتات والحوسبة السحابية
إحدى فوائد
القدرة على حلبة السياج
النظام البيئي
الكامل لمقدمي الخدمات حول
منصة التجارة الإلكترونية
هو أنه يجعل وظيفتك اللوجيستية
فعالة بشكل لا يصدق
لأنك قادر على ذلك  على نطاق واسع مرة أخرى
والقدرة على تحليل تلك البيانات بطريقة
لتكون قادرًا على ربط عمليات تسليم الميل الأخير
من المتاجر التي تروج
لسلعها من خلال البث المباشر
إلى نظام تشغيل الأعمال الذي
يسمح للعلامات التجارية الشريكة بالاستفادة من
الشركة  يتطلب النظام البيئي
[الموسيقى]
لسيطرة علي بابا على
قطاع التجارة الإلكترونية في الصين البالغة قيمته 1.94 تريليون دولار
احتضانًا كاملاً للتحول الرقمي
ديفيد كولفر سي إن إن